hey guys I'm Lucy and welcome to in two
minutes
now the nights are getting longer the
weather is getting colder and the battle
for video game queue for supremacy is
kicking off that's right it's September
which means it's time for the big two
football behemoths to rekindle their
ongoing feud to win over the hearts
minds and most importantly hard-earned
cash of gamers worldwide so what are the
big differences between Pez and FIFA
this year don't worry I know the score
all right let's start with the big
difference between the two this year
FIFA has female teams and PES does not
top female squads have been scanned and
animated for FIFA 16 and they played
differently to the men offering a
slightly slower and more measured
approach and you won't be able to pit
the men's teams against the women's
now pitha has always had the upper hand
when it comes to signing those famous
faces and licenses this year featuring
the likes of 12 national women's teams
big name men's teams from across the
globe and 50 real world stadiums but
Paris has started to catch up snatching
the UEFA Champions League Europa League
and the upcoming UEFA Euro 2016 from
under the nose of its competitor
while it doesn't feature as many iconic
grounds and Konami hasn't scanned as
many faces as FIFA the old fan favorite
edit mode makes a return so if you don't
mind a little graft and you're playing
on ps3 or ps4 you can recreate your
favorite teams at will
FIFA's insanely popular online
collectible card game ultimate team is
back buff a FIFA 16 EA are introducing
foot draft a side foot team that you
select from a random draft of players
you can then take the side team online
and compete for awards for your main
footballers munitions 2-foot also
include various UI improvements and new
legendaries like George best and ryan
giggs so where is the PES equivalent
mode my club hasn't reached the crazy
popularity of foots 11 million players
just yet
it is scrambling to introduce new
features like the ability to turn unused
players into trainers adding a new
player level system and having mode
exclusive footballers
and finally let's talk about general
gameplay tweaks and tweaks is definitely
the word to use FIFA 15 was very attack
heavy for 16 EA are really focusing on
improving defending and midfield
offering a more rounded gameplay
experience pairs on the other hand has
worked on improving its all-out
important collision so there's no more
can't animations and everything feels a
bit more fluid as well as having
improved physics and AI systems offering
more control and improved team dynamics
than in previous games so after all that
au pairs United or ru fee for city be
sure to let me know in the comment
section below or come find me on Twitter
I'm Malou see James games see you next
time